[Musique]
faire de sa voiture un véhicule
d'exception c'est ça le tuning ça nous
vient d'angleterre et c'est à la mode
christophe à 32 ans il est
kinésithérapeute
il vient du nord de la france et sa
voiture c'est une vraie discothèque
ambulante lecteur laser six haut
parleurs à l'avant et deux énormes à
l'arrière bref son truc c'est la musique
et ça s'entend
en puissance il ya 400 watts rms et
qu'elle soit réelle bon ça correspond à
environ la vitesse par le niveau de
bruit d'un 747 au décollage
enfin c'est pas fait pour ça qu'on s'est
fait surtout pour la qualité sans fin
pour moi il y en a c'est plus boum boum
mais à mon niveau c'est plutôt la
qualité et une installation sophistiquée
comme celle ci ça prend de la place et
c'est pas toujours pratique
les questions sont démontables mais
c'est vrai que quand je vais au
supermarché je mets mes courses à
l'arrière par terre j'ai pas là j'ai pas
le choix
mais le tuning c'est aussi tout
l'esthétique de la voiture calandre
jantes volant tous les accessoires y
passe sans oublier la couleur une
couleur qui tape à l'oeil
à l'extérieur comme à l'intérieur et
même sous le capot on est bien se faire
voir et puis des mais que les gens
regardent une belle voiture
si vous avez une belle voiture et que
vous aimez ce que vous faisiez c'est
bien le plaisir pour tous ces adeptes du
tuning c'est de rouler au volant d'une
voiture qui ne ressemble à aucune autre
mais certains l'avouent ils ne
conduisent leurs petits bijoux qu'elle
dimanche
[Musique]
le tuning c'est ça transformer sa
voiture à outrance tout accessoire
décoratif est superflu trouve sa place
la dérision ce fait reine comme ici à
montlhéry ou en juillet tous les
passionnés se réunissent celui ci a
installé des gaz fumigènes pour appuyer
l'impression de vitesse en roulant celui
là à transformer le haut parleur de sa
voiture en pataugeoire ados femmes
[Musique]
on
le plaisir ultime le voici parader dans
les rues souvent en bandes sans le dire
il s'agit du concours de celui qui aura
effectué le plus grand nombre de
transformations
chacun aime se comparer à l'autre mais
pour être le plus beau cela coûte cher
chifflet je pourrais pas chiffré je
pourrais te dire un prix que je la
vendrai parce que
je sais pas fournir vous mettez dans la
voiture
nathan drake je me calme parce que j'ai
en fait ces jeunes achètent souvent des
petites gti d'occasions pour environ 30
mille francs auxquels ils ajoutent
fréquemment plus de cent mille francs
d'accessoires le plus cher étant la sono
tu pourrais ce que vous mettez vos sacs
à provisions normalement la cr qui est
destiné spécialement aux concours de
saut no 6 a calé disque qui existent
uniquement pour être entendu dans les
concours nationaux
voilà c'était laser qui sont inquiets
que les bassins
[Musique]
le concours de sonos et laisser juger sa
voiture par des professionnels de la
hi-fi équipés de micros et d'appareils
de mesure pour fédérer tout ce petit
monde des clubs de tuning se sont créés
ils se donnent rendez vous le soir
souvent sur des parkings pour imaginer
l'inimaginable la grande récompense voir
sa voiture en photo dans les magazines
spécialisés monétaire les gens
connaissent maintenant club aidés il dit
cet art est quoi le son et l'image de la
voiture un spectacle auquel ces jeunes
ne sont pas près de renoncer
[Musique]